this guy is amazing amazing it balances
anything on anything yes he can
this is Nam Suk Beyond from Seoul South
Korea also known as rocky rocky can
bounce any type of object he's honed his
incredible talent by practicing every
day for the last nine years but to the
untrained eye this looks impossible so
how is rocky wrangling gravity it's hard
to balance certain objects because
sometimes the mass distribution can be
pretty complex yep like on a teapot or a
scooter or a big log and finding that
point at which gravity's acting can be
pretty hard rocky knows that regardless
of shape every object has the center of
gravity he just has to find it once he's
discovered the object's center of
gravity
he simply positions it directly above a
contact point with the ground but to
make life easier rocky has a helper
little rocky now notice that he always
has some little stone or rock that he
balanced things on I think they give him
a non smooth surface so he can have more
friction points such that it doesn't
slide in one direction or another
he almost into it with his body where to
tilt it and in which direction to move
the object so that he immediately aligns
the center of gravity directly above the
basis of support and then manages to
hold objects that look pretty impossible
don't you just hate it when that happens